es un conflicto que parece no tener fin
marruecos y la población del sáhara
occidental están enfrentados desde
1976 por la ocupación de marruecos y
mauritania tras la descolonización de
españa desde que se firmó la paz en 1991
el frente polisario exige un referendo
de autodeterminación
una proposición muy distinta a la de
marruecos que en 2007 propuso ante
naciones unidas un proyecto de autonomía
bajo su tutela
el gobierno marroquí presentó su
propuesta al secretario general de
naciones unidas esta propuesta no es más
que propaganda peligrosa y nos acerca
más a la guerra que a la paz de luchar
del dispendio mont ahora la comunidad
internacional concretamente naciones
unidas reconoce el derecho a la
autodeterminación del pueblo saharaui
aunque algunos países también se han
posicionado con marruecos en los últimos
años ha habido una tendencia hacia
la marroquinización
de la cuestión en eeuu hace dos años con
la administración trump decidió
a apoyar la posición marroquí sobre la
cuestión y ayer pues españa se ha sumado
a esa posición españa siempre se ha
posicionado como neutral y apoyar a
marruecos podría salirle caro y es que
argelia es el principal aliado y
protector del frente polisario y a la
vez proporciona más del 50 por ciento
del gas españa a través de dos
gasoductos uno que va directamente desde
argelia a españa y otro que pasa por
marruecos y está inoperativo justo por
el conflicto del sáhara los expertos
opinan que españa quiere evitar una
nueva crisis migratoria como la del 2021
supuestamente forzada por marruecos tras
que madrid acogiera en secreto a un
líder del frente polisario